[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
the brexit saga continues a deeply
divided British House of Commons could
only seem to agree on one thing it
doesn't want the UK to leave the EU
without a deal the problem is there
isn't a parliamentary majority on what
to do next
maybe this was to resumes plan all along
Briggs a death through inertia
[Music]
Ross knocking brexit I'm joined by my
guess we're now Gerard in Paris he's the
chief foreign correspondent of the
Figaro in London we have George Galloway
he is a broadcaster a writer and a
former member of parliament and also in
London we have Alan skip he is a
professor emeritus of international
history at the London School of
Economics all right gentlemen crosstalk
rules in effect that means you can jump
in any time you want and I always
appreciate George let me go to you first
here we've had a - very disastrous votes
for at resumes plan the there has been a
move that there there will be no exit
without a deal the deal is supposed to
be voted on again like the two first
votes it doesn't appear that that's
going to move forward and you have the
European Commission basically saying
that's the deal you negotiated we
there's a little wiggle room maybe for
invoking article 50 but not much more
than that they've pretty much put up by
a stone wall here where do we go from
this because like I said in my
introduction one cynic and I certainly
am could say this was planned all along
go ahead George
I don't think so of course the
conspiracy theorist would be hard to
push to come up with a conspiracy which
had worked just as perfectly as this one
as it happens because I know the people
involved personally I think it's more a
cock-up a series of blunders and
inadequacies that have led us to this
particular pass but in a way it doesn't
matter whether it was intended or
whether it's a series of accidents the
British Parliament has betrayed the
British people with grave consequences
for British democracy because more
people voted for brexit than have ever
voted in Britain's history for anything
or anybody and they're not going to get
it and they're not going to get it
because of the actions of just 650
people indeed in the recent vote just
four people four people made the
decision not to keep no deal on the
table
and if you don't have no deal on the
table you have no possibility of a
negotiated settlement as any new
and even the simplest house purchase
knows if you ask you the right the
determination to walk away if the price
isn't right if the deal isn't right then
you're more or less handing to your
interlocutor the power of life and death
over you you know
yeah but Alan II where do we go from
here because like I said in my
introduction there's no majority in the
house to go in one direction or another
I mean this is the ultimate stalemate
but the clock is ticking and as I
pointed out the European Union is
basically saying we're looking at our
watch what are you guys going to do go
ahead Alan well I agree very much as
what George Galloway said the elite in
Parliament has betrayed the the will of
the British people I think what's going
to happen now is that may will try for a
third time to get her dreadful agreement
passed in the House of Commons if it is
passed then of course we leave with that
agreement and we leave quite early if
it's not passed then
confusion reigns I think she would have
to have a general election I think
they're the governments of shambles
it looks very general election won't
solve the dilemma will it it'll just be
a different person there go ahead Alan
well why not solve the dilemma but it
will get rid of a lot of people in
Parliament the new independent group
would probably disappear labour I think
would be would suffer enormous Lee I
think there'd be a purge inside the Tory
Party before the election and there
would be a different House of Commons
and thereafter of course we still had
the brexit dilemma if if her deal hasn't
been agreed then I don't know that in
the new House of Commons might might go
for no deal but as it stands at present
you're right there's no obvious way
forward but I think a general election
might help police to clear things up
okay now let me go to you in Paris I
mean as they on the continent yourself
looking at all of this going on here
what what is the perspective of the uu
here I mean they have a deal they've
made it very
for weeks and weeks and weeks now but a
deal is a deal
but Tresemme keeps flying over trying to
make you guys budge but you're not so I
mean is is it seems to me that you know
she doesn't have much of a learning
curve and is to resume a good
negotiating partner when it comes to
this whole dreadful process go ahead in
Paris I mean in the continent in Paris
it shows us three things first thing is
that David Cameron made a mistake yep to
go to a referendum for internal affairs
for the Conservative Party because
actually you know British democracy is
based on the House of Commons for the
last I don't know eight nine centuries
they shall not go to this kind of Latin
instrument which is a referent of
argument in this farce the second thing
if I can definitely what we think in the
continent the they the the second thing
is that there was a deal agreed I mean
we you cannot negotiate between it very
difficult to negotiate between one
country and 27 country so mission money
was given a mandate by the 27 but the 27
are not going to change their minds all
the time
it's too difficult it's a technical
question so and after all Anna's about
to Britain to adopt they decided to join
a European Union after refusing to join
it join the common maken at 57 General
de Gaulle warns them twice they should
not enter that they could not enter that
was not the the spirit they they they
the interest they still wanted to enter
they entered and then they made a lot of
problems to the European Union so you
know the you have to you have to
understand that the the European
countries from the continent
I quite upset and quite tired of this
farce and they want just you know you
want to leave or not I mean they want a
simple capture they cannot spend a
little time dogs in this I get your
point here let me Cowen you want to jump
in here but I love this Latin insult
hang on hang on here okay I knew this
was gonna happen we heard we heard the
the the the British caused a lot of
problems for the EU but a lot of the
British voters it was the EU that was
the problem I just correct go Alan go
can I just say on the question of
referendums people should need
constitutional questions like Scottish
devolution Welsh devolution the election
of a mayor for London we now have an
established tradition that Parliament
allows the population to decide these
issues in referendums and we abide by
the results I mean I know the French had
a referendum in 2005 on the
constitutional treaty they voted it down
and then the French government paid no
attention to it and the Lisbon Treaty
which was the same thing was ran through
the French parliament so I do think we
need lessons and referendums from the
French but in any case we have a
tradition of abiding by referendums
which are now part of our Constitution
and we had a referendum the people voted
to get out and the people's you must be
respected otherwise we'll be a popular
backlash okay George George I mean the
elites failed not the people go ahead
George
we don't want to give you less we do not
give you less problems we just see this
pom Monsieur Poirot Monsieur someone
here in London talk we have been a net
if you think that the British democracy
will this Parliament
well fine with you we don't think it
works very well
George Galloway George Galloway go ahead
yeah we're a net contributor for 45
years so we've been paying more into the
EU than we ever got back second and you
would never suspect it from the arrogant
French but your friend mrs. Thatcher mr.
Gallow you've run your big friend mrs.
such got her check back didn't she
yeah that shows that shows what you know
that shows what you yes yes you gotta
check back in check back they hate them
they hate the EU they hate the austerity
they hate the European Central Bank the
reason you can't have referendums on
this in most of the European Union
countries is because they would vote to
leave also it is completely absurd this
false dichotomy between Latin and Nordic
democracy democracy is democracy is
democracy we were asked and we were told
it would be binding
do you want to leave we voted to leave
leave we must and the more we hear of
that kind of arrogant drivel the more
certain I am the more people in Britain
today would vote to leave than dead in
I want we have a minute before we go to
the break let's go back to Paris please
react yes it's a pity that you you see
Britain when they join a club they have
to make a referendum every generation
because I remember that after joining
the the the you know Heath government
joining and then there's a Labour govern
government coming to London and they
said oh maybe we have to do a referendum
though they made a referendum and if I
recall well but mr. Galloway will come
to my help I guess 2/3 of the British
population had approved to join this
club though they knew very well the
rules
the club you know they had plenty time
study those kids of that club that was
the cousin Charlie goal and off used
twice in the carpenter to make bread and
yes it was a common marketing and then
and then then yes and then they approved
because you cannot move Europe with or
without the approbation of I have to
jump in here gentlemen we're gonna go to
a short break and we'll continue our
discussion on Briggs at stake with RT
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter lamelle
to remind you we're discussing brexit
okay let's go back to Alan in London it
seems to me that the for the political
the elites in both political parties in
the UK the major parties have failed
they had a two-year deadline to get this
done and it just been incompetence after
incompetence after incompetence and
that's why I started out I mean hey you
one has to wonder if this was
intentional because you have a prime
minister that is a remainer negotiating
the exit I mean again that's comical on
its face alright but you know if Ellen
if one thing I see from the European
position and because I look at what's
going on in the the populist movements
in in in Europe and the the collapse of
the center for the most part of this
entire European Union project here is
Brussels behavior and disposition to the
UK during this process actually also was
signal to all other members of the
European Union to stay in line because
if you want to get out we're gonna give
you hell and watch what we're doing to
the UK Alan go ahead yeah I think that's
true Martin Selma who's now heading the
European bureaucracy has made it
perfectly clear that Brussels that
Britain has to pay a price
he thinks surrounding Northern Ireland
should be that price but it's quite
clear that populist dis could tend to
new Europe is growing and growing
Monsieur Matt Cole when he was last in
Britain was asked on television if the
French were given a referendum what the
result would be and he said they would
vote to leave but then he added of
course I'm not going to give them a
referendum the French had a referendum
on the Maastricht Treaty which almost
when people think it was rigged it was
so close and then they had one in the
constitutional treaty which they voted
against so I mean the French have this
tradition of having referendums as well
because on the great issues of the day
when you're voting on your national
future and who makes the laws and who
decides that is such a fundamental
choice that it has to go back to the
people it went back to the people here
and the result astonished not only the
elites from the British political
parties but astonished the elites in
Europe who
had been assured by David Cameron that
he would he would win now the people
have voted that the European Union is
unpopular among a large largeman time a
majority of the British people they want
height and they want a clear break and
the question is for Europe if this is
allowed without a price being paid how
many other members are failing European
Union would follow because Europe is a
disaster now economically the European
currency system isn't working it's led
to the crushing of the Greek economy and
recessions in southern Europe
unemployment in the EU is twice as high
in the rest of the year in the eurozone
is twice as high as in Britain youth
unemployment in southern Europe is
twenty to forty percent you're getting a
hundred to 300,000 young Europeans
coming to Britain voting with the feet
to get out to the eurozone every year to
come and get jobs in London or in
Britain now if we had docked there that
the situation were a hundred three
hundred thousand young Brits were having
to go to Europe to the eurozone to find
work because we had high and massive
unemployment then I would say there was
a case first thing in the EU but the EU
economy is failing the eurozone is
probably going to have another crisis
and implode very quickly and yet these
people in Britain can understand why on
a rational basis people would want to
get out okay all right let me go to
George here and keep going with this
here Georgia I over them the last few
months I've been extremely harsh on to
resume and her parts of her Tory party
but I want to be fair here more balanced
here how is labour behaved through all
of this did have they acquitted
themselves with honor and dignity
because you know the dis recently
talking of a second referendum which to
me again is a slap in the face to
democracy I mean democracy means
democracy doesn't it won a vote outcome
should count shouldn't it so so evaluate
Labour's behavior during all of this
well up until comparatively recently
I would have said the Labour leader
Jeremy Corbyn whom I've known for 40
years had played a blinder in terms of
parliamentary tactics he had maneuvered
the government into a position where it
began and is now accelerated almost to
fall apart but labour put the mark of
Kaine upon their own head when they
announced quite recently in the last few
weeks that they would support the
so-called people's vote as if the first
of all didn't involve people as if it
was you know donkeys horses and sheep
that had voted the first time and when
it did that it allowed people to the
right to brand them as the anti
breakfast party as the anti brexit
manoeuvre us
conspiring in an unprincipled way and so
we now have basically two labor parties
and two conservative parties they are
trapped inside a single first past the
post electoral system and I don't
believe it will survive this crisis
referenda changes the political paradigm
in countries and it will change this one
in a very profound way even the losers
of referendums never accept the result
really here we've got the winners of a
referendum literally cheated in front of
their eyes
right by a privileged elite group of
parliamentarians that cannot withstand
the kind of blizzard that's coming their
way okay we're now back to you in Paris
I mean
there's a quite a bit of animosity
however with the the British Isles in
continental Europe on this program so
why don't you white why don't you have
the attitude good riddance and goodbye
okay I mean me if Britain is such a
nuisance to the EU then good riddance I
mean does it have to be nasty go ahead
in Paris no it does not to be nasty I
mean we'll still be thankful for Britain
for its role during the second world war
never forget that great britain
churchill welcome Charles de Gaulle in
London and will never forget that
Britain campaign for us to get a seat
permanent seat in the Security Council
of un we have a defense agreement with
Britain which is called Lancaster House
because the defense the Europe of
defense of course will never work so we
have this Agreement which is very strong
and we have a close to to the British
and well the British had problems with
the Argentinians in 82
the Americans dropped of the British but
the fence want to help them so we are
very close to the to the British and we
want to to stay close they're armed
they are very good friends it's very
it's for me it's a quite a bit II to see
a country destroying itself but after
all it's up to the people why I said
destroying this servic is you know for
me the whole policy of Britain for the
last three centuries was two things keep
a foot on the continent you remember
that it was important for them to beat
Bonaparte and to be important in the
Vienna Congress of 1815 so keep always a
foot on the continent and the second
pillar of British policy was keep
British Islands United in 1/9
they have sabotaged have destroyed all
this policy because they will not keep a
foot in the continent good chance with
the relationship with America only and
then they
they will destroy the unity of the
British Islands because I think that the
Scottish people want to remain in Europe
so it's very pity because we have a lot
of respect for this great country which
is Great Britain but we will always be
friend we just do not understand and
well certainly okay well I do not David
Cameron is the worst British Prime
Minister after Lord North well I think
that the competition for the worst Prime
Minister you know you could spend a lot
of time on it because there's a lot of
candidates recently okay I also I just
want to finish off in Paris err I mean
you do have a NATO footprint okay in
Europe so I wouldn't be so worried about
not being in Europe you're there oh and
go ahead could I could I just say that
that view of British history is quite
flawed the Great Britain is a uniform
was a nomadic surely the great Union
the great British traditional foreign
policy was actually to remain
independent and to make sure that
continental Europe was never United
either under the Spanish the Hapsburgs
the Napoleon the Kaiser or Hitler and we
stayed outside we didn't have a
foodstuff and here in Britain we were in
Europe we stayed outside any Europe and
getting into the European Union was
quite against the whole British foreign
policy tradition and now we're going to
correct that I hope by getting out I I
think the British point of view is that
Europe works best as a collection of
friendly slightly competitive nation
states who take from each other the best
practice commercially intellectually
philosophically what happened the Common
Market the Common Market was we go but
where's the Golden Age of growth after
the Second World War was the common yeah
but nothing had nothing to do with the
EU that's my that's my point
exactly my point is matter of fact if
you look at growth patterns
since the unification of the EU it
slowed down dramatically and yeah
the morning's remark and its trademark
is austerity that's its trademark yeah
the more the you know the more the
European Union integrates the slower its
economy becomes and now it's the sort of
slowest growing part of the well I want
to give George I want to give George the
last word 45 seconds my friend finish
and I give you an advice can you can you
go and visit Poland go and have a visit
in Poland just a little advice go and
visit Poland both of you not far from
Moscow okay 20 second short we could
tour we could tour the barrios of young
unemployed right across southern Europe
we could we could make a trip to the
smoking ruin of the Greek economy we
could go to Italy we could - of the
horizont
and we will find that the European Union
has less support inside Europe than it
has ever had and the reason is that it
ceases to be a comic all right on that
began that no George Sheldon many thanks
to my guests in London and in Paris and
thanks to our viewers for watching us
here at RT see you next time and
remember Rostock rules